foreign
[Music]
news briefing for Tuesday February 14th
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
1 in 10 partnered adults that's people
who are married living with a partner or
in a committed romantic relationship say
they met their current significant other
on a dating site or app
those results are from a Pew Research
Center report published earlier this
month that same report found a majority
of U.S adults surveyed are skeptical
about whether the programs that underlie
those apps can actually find love
matches
to understand a little more about this
discrepancy and the role technology can
play in finding us love I'm joined by
Liesel sharabi she's an associate
professor at Arizona State University
and the director of the relationships
and Technology Lab at ASU hi professor
sharabi thanks for joining me thanks for
having me on so you don't work with any
of the dating apps but from a high level
can you kind of explain how they work I
mean so many of us use them these days
but what's going on behind the scenes
so a lot of these platforms are using
algorithms to match people and
algorithms are used to recommend people
to you on a dating app a lot like how
Amazon would recommend a product or how
Netflix might recommend a movie that you
would want to watch but unlike products
people have to reciprocate your
interests so it's not enough that you
like someone you also have to think
about is this person also going to be
interested in you in return and so in
that sense these algorithms have to be
more complex and they have to take that
reciprocity into account when they're
forming matches between people what's
the difference between say apps where
you maybe swipe on somebody you're
interested in versus apps where you
answer a load of questions and then
you're maybe presented with potential
matchups well on some dating apps
they're having people self-report their
preferences by asking them questions
about what they're looking for about
themselves in general and then they're
doing their best to deliver somebody
who's going to meet those criteria now
the issue that comes into play when you
ask people what they're looking for is
that sometimes what we think we're going
to find attractive and what we actually
find attractive can be two very
different things so you might think you
wouldn't date somebody who is under 6-1
but the reality is that if they were
charming and you really connected that
you wouldn't pay attention to something
like that
now on a lot of dating apps especially
recently they're starting to skip over
that process and they're just having
people start swiping with the idea being
that they're going to figure out what
your taste is and what your preferences
are by just looking on the types of
profiles that you engage with and so
they are going to know what your type is
without actually having to take the time
to ask you so a lot of dating apps today
are using something called a
collaborative filtering algorithm where
they're making recommendations based on
the behaviors of people who have similar
taste to you
so as a basic example say you're swiping
on an app and you swipe right to
indicate that you like a guy named Mike
the app might consider okay who else has
swiped right on Mike we see that those
people also like Josh so now we might
serve up Josh as your next
recommendation so they don't have to ask
you what you're looking for they can
just kind of figure it out based on how
you're engaging with profiles technology
has really changed the way we interact
with humans at all levels I mean the
telephone made it easier to connect
email connected us to people who are
farther away has using dating apps
changed the kinds of relationships we've
had I mean I think that they're giving
us a lot more options than we used to
have because if you think of what we did
before we had dating apps you were kind
of at the mercy of the people you might
come across just going about your
day-to-day routine like who you meet at
the gym who you meet at work or at
school and so I think that one of the
really great things that dating apps do
for people is that they just open up the
dating pool beyond your immediate
Network and even beyond your immediate
Community to introduce you to a lot more
people than you would have had access to
previously what about incentives for the
dating apps themselves yeah I mean
there's different ways that you can look
at this because on the one hand it makes
the app look really good if they're
helping people form successful
relationships you would think that that
would be a a desirable outcome but at
the same time when people are successful
in finding a long-term relationship if
that's what they're looking for then
those are people who will ultimately
leave the app and I want to talk a
little bit more about how these apps are
developed in the first place what goes
into them if I'm you know a new app
developer I want to start a dating app
am I starting with with math am I
starting with a focus group of gossipy
grandmas from my neighborhood how do you
start these I mean one thing that you
really need are users and so one of the
number one things that I think people
look for when they're deciding which
dating app to sign up for is just how
many people are there is it going to
expand their opportunities to meet
someone and so with users like the best
way to get users is to have users that's
going to attract people and so I think
that that's definitely something to
think about is just where are the people
going to come from and how can you make
sure that people are going to find the
type of crowd that they actually want
like I think of these dating apps kind
of like Singles bars where everyone has
a different crowd it has a different
culture and so people also look for
individuals that are what they want that
are what they're looking for in a
relationship and they look for their
crowd on these apps and so also thinking
about your demographics and who you're
trying to appeal to can help you know
technology doesn't stop with apps you've
done some research on immersive and
virtual reality dating can you take us
through how that might change dating in
the future yeah at this point this is
all very speculative because I think
that right now A lot of people are still
getting to used to the idea of video
dating so the idea of virtual reality
dating sounds really far-fetched but
when I think about what this space is
going to look like in five or ten years
the idea of just engaging with people
over text and swiping on profiles I
think that that leaves a lot of room for
improvement and when I think of virtual
reality dating I think of really taking
dating back to its roots and allowing
people to meet more organically so right
now you swipe on profiles in virtual
reality you might have the chance to
walk up to somebody at a virtual bar and
just sit down and start talking while
still having all of the advantages of a
dating app where you can read more about
somebody where you can see a profile but
I think that it allows people to get to
know each other as individuals rather
than getting to know each other through
a profile I want to talk about some news
that we can maybe
you're using a dating app are there kind
of best ways to use it to make sure that
you are finding you know the right
matches so one thing that people can do
is get out there and just meet people I
think that sometimes you spend a lot of
time swiping and talking without taking
that next step of actually meeting
somebody in person and so that can be
very time consuming it can be very
draining and also spending that time
interacting with somebody in a on a
dating app doesn't necessarily give you
a sense of what it's going to be like to
interact with them in person so using
the apps more as a way of being
introduced to people and then doing the
real dating face to face where you can
get a better sense of what it's like to
engage with them Professor sharabi thank
you so much for joining us for this
conversation thank you and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories head over to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal home thanks for listening
[Music]